When the Federal Reserve
does traditional open-market
operations, what they
do is the Fed over here
will literally print money.
So it prints money.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be cash,
it could be electronic money.
And it uses that money to buy
usually short-term treasury
securities in the open market.
That's why it's called
open market operations.
So in exchange it gets
treasury securities.
Now, the whole
purpose of this, it
does increase the
demand for treasuries,
and, therefore, increases
the price on treasuries
and lower the interest rate.
But the main point is it
takes this printed money,
and it puts it in
the banking system.
Because it buys treasuries just
from people, or from banks,
or institutions, and then
those people take that cash,
that they just got
for these treasuries,
and they'll deposit it in banks.
So they'll go and they'll
deposit it in, maybe,
Bank 1 over here, then
over here in Bank 2.
And since there's more
money in Bank 1 and Bank 2,
you have the supply
of money going up,
and also the demand for
reserves is going up.
This cash right here,
these are reserves.
So you have the demand
for reserves going down.
Maybe before this money
entered the system,
maybe Bank 2 is running
low on reserves.
But now people have
deposited money in Bank 2,
so Bank 2 doesn't
need it as much.
And if you have the
supply of money going up,
you have the demand
for money going down--
where in particular I'm
talking about reserves.
I'm talking about
base-money right over here--
then the overnight
borrowing rate between banks
will go down.
The price of money will go down.
And that's what the
federal funds rate is.
It's the target rate.
So I'll say fed funds rate.
It's the target
rate that the Fed
sets for the overnight borrowing
of reserves between banks.
That's the federal funds
rate, and it will go down.
And that's how the Fed tries
to set the federal funds rate.
Now, fast forward to a
situation like we are right now.
And the federal funds
rate is already at 0,
but the Fed still wants to pump
more money into the economy
and it wants to do it
in a more directed way.
So now what it's doing,
it's still printing money,
but it's using that money
to buy other things.
It could buy longer-term debt.
So it could buy longer
duration treasuries.
So things that are
maybe going to,
maybe 10-year treasury bonds,
or further out than even that.
Or it could even buy
completely different assets.
It could maybe buy
mortgage backed securities.
And the point here isn't just
to increase the money supply.
The point in quantitative
easing is, maybe,
to kind of smooth
over what's happening
in certain parts of the market.
So if they think that there's
a logjam in the mortgage backed
security market, that's why
they're participating there.
So this right over here,
that is quantitative easing.